can you explain so after your wife split
uh when you guys got back together could
you walk me through slowly like what the
first [ __ ] was like
[Music]
welcome back to another Splendid episode
of the careful boys we have with us men
AKA what's your mortgage what's a
mortgage and we got him in the hot seat
for this one oh the way Hachi works is
oh I watched it today let's go let's see
what did you watch what was your wife
oh I saw that quietness in your face
we went easy on her too though yeah we
did we did go easy on her uh so we're
just gonna ask you a series of questions
they're gonna get increasingly hotter in
temperature but as tradition we always
like to start out with Bart giving the
possible coldest question that you could
think of okay this is a cold one you
ready yeah
what you can only make sounds okay what
does a rainbow sound like
question
[Laughter]
but there's seven colors though you
didn't hear all seven the seven
frequencies in that that is a false of
our ears yeah okay that's that yeah is
that good enough yeah okay all right
what is one degree hotter than that
weakest question when did you first get
into business for yourself
uh
uh when did I get a business for myself
drug dealing counts too a drug dealing
it doesn't be registered llc's in uh in
high school we would go home we would
pass this liquor store that threw away
their old
um Playboy Hustlers so we would take it
out of the trash and then we'd sell it
to people in the Navy kids in the
neighborhood so how did you find that
they had old that's [ __ ] magazines I
thought that [ __ ] they would just throw
out a trust one day you just saw a
magazine stacked up my buddy saw it and
he was smart we like he left at my house
so he doesn't get in trouble
that's pretty smart I remember I will
take it out of the trash my mom would
came out with this black bag and like my
stomach just dropping on it you Hardy
Boy
yo but that's interesting how many
months back are the issues that they
throw away
um like when do they expire I didn't
know they threw away Magnus hustle and
never expired only 36 Days like you know
the magazine would expire and they just
need to make shelf rooms yeah and they
would just toss them out
videos and they know about video VHS
back in the days with big boxes so you
actually just threw away the boxes but
the boxes were so big like so we would
just sell those to your classmates and
stuff correct correct that's a [ __ ]
dope ass house if you're watching this
I'm not ratting you out oh that's one of
the smartest like kid hustles I've ever
heard of dude sex to kids come on now
bro yeah
everyone passed around that floppy disk
or something like somebody somebody's
dad they stole their dad's Playboy or
something like that you would have to
put on like [ __ ] gloves and like that
was so in condition out the plastic you
know but to have a [ __ ] Playboy plug
as a kid who the hustlers was like the
high paying one in Penthouse because
that's when you saw the real
in another video uh you talked about how
there's one point where you're making
600 G's a month yeah what was the
smartest thing you ever spent your money
on and what was the dumbest thing you
ever spent your money on uh during that
like super baller period uh the smartest
thing I ever spent money on was
reinvesting it in other other branches
to keep growing so you have to reinvest
your money to make money so that was
like the smartest thing what do you mean
by branches let's say I wanted them
um a bunch of loan officers that were
for another company come over I would re
invest in them I would open up another
office for them I would put them there I
would cover some costs so you're
building your business out by expanding
other correct oh yeah spending money the
stupidest thing I bought um I had a
Bentley and I sold it for a Lamborghini
that I never drove at all and then I
sold it again and I think that because I
was you know
drugged out of my mind just didn't do
the numbers correctly and just it's cool
to have a Lamborghini but you never
drove it because you just didn't once
you realize what the [ __ ] did I just buy
and then you then I had to sell it all I
had a lot just to like dump it off wow
how much was the Bentley the Bentley I
end up getting it for like one I think
130 140. so I gave away my Bentley that
was worth more than the lambo and I came
I paid the difference because uh I
wanted this matted black on black and of
course through that time I wasn't
thinking straight and I got hustled from
these these other guys who were like uh
selling these cars I'm like oh I want my
belly back it was nicer than the lambo
because if you drive a Lamborghini
you're like you know not even driving my
brother drove I would sit in the
passenger and I'm like oh my God why did
I do this it was probably the worst
mistake ever wow so how much was a Lambo
do you remember
it was ah man so the I think it was like
150 170 for the for the um for the for
the Bentley and when I sold it I sold it
for 110 and then I had to cover the
difference of the lambo I think it's
like 150 160 so it's like out of camera
for a car I could have gotten I sold my
car to take less to put more money in oh
yeah yeah yeah it's stupid and you just
paid it cash you're just correct no just
oh yeah that was like stupid okay okay
what's the most you've ever profited on
a single transaction
most I ever tried profited a single
transaction it was like this was before
the crash I think it was like all right
right probably right before the crash it
was like 2000 to 2004 I was like forty
thousand dollars forty fifty thousand on
a transaction on this uh this Hawaiian
guy who lived who had a place in New
York and he needed the castle was like
[Music]
he had a club uh I lived there and he
was like hakan something I don't want to
say he's laughing hakan something so it
was in uh New York before you know the
crash Avenue eight and he needed some to
get a hard money loan and I gave him the
loan and like dude I was like was that
50 like seeing all that money at one
time like wow blew my mind how um so you
own a mortgage company how does a
mortgage company make money uh well we
were like a small company how we make
money is we originate the loan someone
comes to us gives us um you know they
want to get a loan and then when they
come to us to get a loan we get it for
them then whatever interest rate we
increase we the bank pays us that
incentive oh I see so let's say you get
the the the the bank to give you the
money
and the interest rate is like two
percent and then you stack on whatever
percentage on top of that to the person
you're lending to and then you make
money on the difference uh it's kind of
like uh whatever the bank is willing to
pay for that interest rate so let's say
and the numbers change and it's hard to
there's no actual calculation on on my
side at least let's say you gave it a
four percent but instead of giving four
percent which is like the party where
you it's like you buy this cup of coffee
for five bucks you sell for five bucks
you're not gonna make any money well you
sell for 575 you're gonna make 75 cents
yeah so the higher you increase it the
more you make of course you want to see
what's out on the fair market like oh
everyone else is selling for six bucks
so let me sell it for 5.75 I make looks
like I'm giving them a discount that's
where I'm making the difference so your
company's taking
the bottled money from the bank and then
you're putting your interest on top of
it they gave us the industry what
they're willing to buy that logo they're
like hey today in pools of buckets we're
going to buy all loans at five percent
at this price five and a quarter at this
five price five and a half of this price
so when you guys get do you guys get the
money like like from the monthly
payments that that they're paying you
the the tenants or the uh person who got
the mortgage is paying or is it a lump
sum uh that money is paid to the
servicer so whoever's like servicing the
low monthly they make a little bit of
that money from the payment uh we get
paid directly from the bank whoever's
buying the loan so let's say we fund the
loan and then we sell to this Bank
they're paying US dollars but if you
miss any pay they miss any payments or
they refinance out within six months you
got to pay back the commission okay so
during your
um hyper Ballin era would you say did
you have a drug problem yes a serious
drug problem what was it like I think it
was pretty much cooked down most of the
times dollars your preferred weapon of
choice yes cocaine like I did the the E
for a while I didn't I had one bad K
trip but mostly cocaine because cocaine
and Hennessy huh [ __ ] Vietnamese
because you know you think about uh you
have all these employees working for you
everyone calling you need something from
you every day it's like everyone's
pulling at you and it just keeps you
aware it's kind of like Limitless but it
is limited because once it gets off you
become very limited oh so you were on
coke while working yes correct like I
would I'd probably do it during the
daytime just to stay like mentally sane
it wasn't even I wasn't even doing it to
uh get [ __ ] up to get messed up
anymore yeah I was just doing this to
like maintain so it started off from
parting and then it went into just like
this is mine that's that Matthew
McConaughey [ __ ] Wolf of Wall Street
type cocaine you know midday lunch you
want some you gotta stay in the business
what was the uh what was the turnaround
point that you decided whoa this is
getting too much when I lost everything
in 2017. oh okay when 2017 people
started I left uh this morning company
to start my own company and then in 2017
when it's I could feel it like leaving
me you ever feel like the power just
leaving you whatever you were whatever
you were good at you just feel like
getting ripped out of you like you know
what let me keep fighting through let me
get fighting through then at the end of
probably November 2017 I'm in this
building by myself with no employees
everyone's just gone left owing like 1.7
million bucks of debt [ __ ] God damn so
you were telling us earlier that you and
your wife had a Rocky Point what was the
closest you guys came to splitting up
so in 2018 we sold our house just so we
because we couldn't afford it anymore
she uh that's when we split and when we
split she you know rented somewhere else
well I moved home until I figure out
like because she told me why stress
about being a husband don't stress about
being a father right now seems like you
have a lot of things to figure out
um we're gonna go live here you know
once you have your situation fixed
you know you're always welcome to come
back how many kids the anxiety I had
like oh my gosh if I don't get my [ __ ]
together soon yeah she's gonna leave she
would have bounced yeah for sure one son
do you still have one son yeah okay wait
wait you're being uh very very is she
Vietnamese she's Mexican she's Mexican
okay never mind
I'm saying she's Vietnamese are you
being rational and saying it like that
like you're welcome to come back or was
it more like you better get your [ __ ]
straight don't [ __ ] touch me but you
know what I mean is it like way crazy I
know like you know she's like she sounds
great by the way yeah she's a little
level-headed like that's that's she
didn't like oh she was mad at me she was
mad through the whole time but she like
sometimes like I don't know why she
didn't leave me like I am like sometimes
I thank God like dude why didn't you
leave me you know damn she really
believes in you yeah how come she'd and
her son didn't end up moving in with you
guys because then if I have to be a
father every day be a husband how can I
reverse 1.7 million bucks in debt and a
lot of the debt too was under my
brother's name because you know when we
started the business my brother had the
best credit he came on the military you
know so he was like VA so like it's a
veteran business you have to make good
on your brother too so did you both
fight for this together or no I didn't
no he he just had to go on with his life
so I would sit stuck there fixing this
1.7 million bucks by myself so he had to
fix his credit yes I had to make sure
that there was no judgments no lean
things that his credit stays where it's
at I remember keep his good name yeah I
had to borrow money from somebody just
to make the AmEx payment
and I had to borrow a lot and then it
went through some crazy system where
like through PayPal the guy tried to
reverse it I was like I got trouble with
PayPal it was like crazy times you know
did you ever within that desperate time
did you ever consider getting into some
shady ass [ __ ] to try to pay this off no
I literally was pretty much kind of
suicidal at this moment like you know
what this is like I have the world in my
fingertips like how did you [ __ ] up so
bad what prevented you from actually
like coming soon my son my son is like
you know what
I don't want his dad I don't want him to
think his dad was a [ __ ] how old is
your dad I mean your how old is your son
uh he's seven so at that time he was uh
two
um
can you explain so after your wife split
uh when you guys got back together could
you walk me through slowly like with the
first [ __ ] was like
I say about it it was probably a year
two years into it because I didn't feel
like a man looked like my dick was the
size of a gummy bear sometimes it was
more of an innie than an Audi for so
long because like I think with men it's
all in the I think it's all in the head
yeah so it's like even if she wanted to
just was like I was pissing on my balls
you know what I mean I just couldn't you
know I just so even during the split you
guys would try to hook up here and there
no we didn't at all but then because she
felt like I'm just not there if with
women especially if you're married not
like just some random girl they want
that love they want that intimacy of
like a partner first before having sex
it wasn't like you know oh when we met
and you looked up the first couple times
really quick what the [ __ ] is going on
now it's like because you have a
foundation of a marriage you have a
foundation of emotions it doesn't just
happen overnight so it took like a year
afterwards like even like a year
afterwards yeah it took a while so you
you you you got your [ __ ] together you
had that relief you moved back in and
it's yet to build back that intimacy
that intimacy that trust you know like
the no cocaine the you know like at that
point I Found Jesus again you know like
of course when you lose everything you
find Jesus quick you know what I mean so
just like getting getting back into a
rhythm you know and then believing
yourself again I think the hardest thing
for uh any man or any entrepreneur is
once you lose it all
to believe in yourself again
um would you say that you guys became
stronger though as a result of going
through all that crazy [ __ ] and coming
through on the other side yeah I think
we're a lot stronger now now we
communicate better I think our
relationship is stronger than it ever
was because you know a lot of people
thought she would for sure leave me but
she stuck it out so now before I think
about doing anything stupid or even like
ah let me try this Shady idea you know
in the Asian blood we always got that
gray gray you know we all stay away from
that great great but I think about light
loophole mindset yeah so I think yeah
yeah because she's been like I would
never want to put my wife do any
[ __ ] again you know I never wanted
I've had a couple opportunities
to do some pretty gays or something yeah
yeah because as you get so good at what
you do you see all the holes in places
that you could totally be Shady that's
why I'm like I'm impressed you don't and
then being Asian you have other guys who
are shitty Asians telling you about like
every scam under the book like oh man
I'd rather make less than not even
[ __ ] the [ __ ] because then the
pressure and the stress like you've been
through the stress and you're just you
know what it feels like to have that
stress go away and now it's like I
rather make less but be able to breathe
correct correct growing up did your
parents always believe in you no my
parents did not believe me at all like
when I did well it's like because I had
that chip on my shoulder like I'm
improving raw I'm not gonna finish
college I don't care what my mom says
you know I don't care if my cousin's a
pharmacist or not
um
compare the pharmacists well then what
was what was that like moving back in
with your parents at the lowest part my
mom would tell me like dynamite I know
I'm like oh no I might know I don't know
so my mom's like I told you so I told
you so so what that means yeah and like
it was like coming back for the second
time in 2008 I came back you know but
2008 I was still I was 28 and then you
know 2017 I'm like damn I'm coming back
at that age like that's funny to be in
the room though as like an adult again
and be like [ __ ] you mom like in the
same room you grew up in when you were
13. yeah I'm back I'm back in the same
with your race car bed but
glow-in-the-dark stars in that [ __ ]
ceiling in your Integra type our bed
what about when um sunghee Lee poster
when you were when you were a
hyperballing did you do anything to like
Flex on your parents like this that's
right [ __ ] I paid off their
mortgage oh you did you did what that's
it oh so that means you're going back
into the house you paid off the more
exhaust so you're kind of okay on it
yeah this is my house so that's cool so
like Azure a hyperballing like there
were like almost little alley-oops that
you set yourself up for correct money
all the time so she wants she knows
she'd go to church I see my son you're
smart he's like now she's having all
this good [ __ ] when when things are
going well you know but that means when
you lost everything she lost a little
bit too she kind of got quiet at the
church you know she's like oh no but you
never got into gambling at all no I like
you know some of my friends gambled I
kind of gambled but then never got into
it so your fun was just like partying
blowing money on drugs and that kind of
stuff you know what it was uh yeah it
was like all you know grown up not being
like the cool kid you're out there
everyone worships around you walk on but
you feel so alone and you're doing all
this Yak but you're like you feel alone
in this room while everyone's here
mooching off you but you're okay with it
because you know they accepted you when
your parents or you know your childhood
friends or people you grew up with did
not accept you so you felt like the
popular guy yeah especially in club
table economics yeah you get to take all
the girls go to your table Yeah because
they want free drinks economics yeah it
is it's like a whole ecosystem totally
the girls with the hottest bottle rats
yeah they're trying to get next to your
table yeah
back into a mortgage a little bit um
what would you consider is in the like
real estate kind of entire ecosystem is
like the number one thing that most
people don't know but that is like
almost like a not necessarily a loophole
but like the greatest thing to take
advantage of right now buying investment
properties with these dscr loans what's
a DS a debt service coverage ratio loans
they're buying homes they don't need uh
if you are if you already own one home
you just keep buying homes as rentals
and you're you're putting minimum like
15 20 down and there's no income
required you just keep buying more and
more and more and that's why I think
more investors also there's more
investors now because they were using
this program to kind of get into houses
without you know any tax documents you
know they just run your credit you're
putting the down payment as long as it
rents more than the than the mortgage
payment then they'll give you the loan
so you're talking about homes that are
already rented out and they're selling
investment properties no you're just
going out you're buying them because
think about um
2020 2020 2020 2021 even up till now I
think about when rates were low you were
getting a lot it's pretty much a stated
loan with just 20 down at like a four
five percent interest rate
so of course as rent keeps increasing it
just covers the payment but you are
buying them without tax returns they
don't care you know
be other old programs uh you could only
use 75 of the rent these programs like
allows you to use 100 of the rent
so you can keep buying more property
that's how people
um were just using their equity and
buying more property
and that's how they start building their
empire like let's see so let's say I buy
a home with the dscr loan and then as
long as my rental income is covering the
mortgage this is now safe correct and
now I can use the value of this home to
get another dscr loan no no no now you
have that house you just have to keep
pulling money out of your other house or
you start you know having your group of
friends come together unless you buy
more property so people start buying
these homes out in like uh Big Bear you
know they start they start Palm Springs
they go to that's why we couldn't find a
[ __ ] house in Big Bear yeah
these homes and think about it no matter
what the mortgage is if it's um they
allow you use fair market regular rent
but if you rent it out as an Airbnb or
as a verbo you're cleaning up and that's
how I think a lot of uh this new
millennial generation of investors made
their money oh yeah and it's not too
late to get on that bandwagon you're
saying that's like the thing to do right
now right now it depends on where the
location's at because a lot of locations
a lot of cities have blocked Airbnb or
they've had some restrictions I think
the go-to move right now
is uh now say that [ __ ] off camera yeah
[Music]
so one out of every 20 people who get
divorced uh sell their house within the
first year so if you knew enough divorce
lawyers that tell you okay these people
are getting divorced you start
approaching them whoa you're giving us a
gym right now and they don't want to
list their home on the open market like
they don't want everyone know they just
want to sell and get rid of it get out
of it so they'll take less like hey we
don't want it we just want to dump it we
just want to dump it I'm not going to
take that little of an offer so if you
understand their sentiment you just come
in like cool I'm gonna buy this one I
quote to take it so that's because they
don't have you two people hate each
other's guts
and they're trying to dump it they just
want the cash that's the new cold call
instead of asking are you interested in
selling your home you say how's your
marriage yeah I think that's the the big
pickup of people getting divorced
especially right now during the
recession you know money causes uh
relationship issues yes
[Laughter]
typically one person can
keep the mortgage going let's say two
people break up one person can't afford
the mortgage they're selling they're
just trying to hold off into your life
as long as they can then they want to
dump it so I think those are popular but
not a lot of people know about yeah or
they just don't want the memory attached
to the house because the rental that I
was living in
um it was bought by a couple that was
married and then they divorced and then
they just turned into a rental but it's
doing really well but she was just like
you know what I don't want it and I was
like oh okay cool anyone got a final
hottest question how big is your penis
not that big not that big it's got a
small dick but it got bigger than um uh
the Gummy Bear right
now you feel good about yourself oh last
one last one is a huge question we
usually ask all of our guests would you
rather [ __ ] your mom or your dad
you have to pick one
damn oh man my dad is my stepdad
you got lucky the quickest anybody's
answered that yeah you got the speed
record now dude
[Music]